foreign
is up Lauren how can we help
hey guys uh fun to know that you used to
live in Richmond
um yeah so my boyfriend and I are
currently planning out a potential
feature together so we've been going
through FPU and during that process
um and actually before that process he
shared that in a previous relationship
he co-signed on a student loan with his
girlfriend
um so looking at that we're trying to
figure out do we pay that off is there
any way to like what do we do with that
because she never finished the degree
and so it's not likely that she's going
to pay it off anytime soon
um yeah wow I don't think I've ever
heard this one Rachel this is how long
ago was the relationship
um it ended probably two years ago and
it was three years long oh boy man yikes
well it's the girlfriends yes oh gosh
sorry yeah so sorry Lauren ex-girlfriend
is she is she behind on on payments is
she like where is she is she she's
paying them minimum payments but it's
just gonna
take forever right now it's in
forbearance so before she was paying the
minimum payment yes right now it's on
like hold and all that right but do you
know if she's planning on
at all being aggressive towards this
debt
no idea there's no contact oh did the
relationship end uh peacefully
you know
otherwise it just kind of
kind of so I just wonder is she gonna
try to stick it to him because he
co-signed for it yeah because the only
the only reason as a co-signer are you
kind of screwed is if they stop right
write payments and all of that but if
she continues to pay and it's just I
mean it would suck that she you know if
she has it for the next seven years he's
for seven years he'll be kind of
watching his back being like Oh gosh
you're not going to pay she gonna pay
but if you know but but you guys are
only or he sorry your boyfriend is only
on the hook
when
or if something goes awry do you know
what I mean then yeah then he would be
how much is it
um 20 000 and what we're looking at is
okay so let's say we get married we move
together all that a year from now we go
to buy a house and we've paid off
everything but that student loan is that
like negatively affect our credit score
like should we just pay it off to get
rid of it like what does all of it well
most of it is in her name yeah
um but again
I would want to know what she that's the
thing that sucks about co-signing is I'm
like your future is tied to this other
person right for until until it's until
it's paid off in student loans I mean
they're not bankruptible I mean like
this is a thing that's going to have to
happen so
um man I would hate for him to be the
one she could look if you guys had
contact with her to refinance sometimes
when you refinance you can get
you know
um get a co-signer off of the loan
student loans I'm are they federal or
private
Federal Federal okay
I would look into that Lauren and see
and and it would be worth a conversation
to reaching back out to her even though
it's probably very it's very awkward
um but to see if she would consider
refinancing to get his name off of it
because of his plans moving forward
um but if not I would hate for you guys
to be the ones to go and pay something
that's not yours and if she's not late
on them right like it's not gonna
penalize him
um necessarily but if she is late and
she doesn't pay on then that's the
that's the stupid tax that you pay as a
co-signer unfortunately and I and I also
hate to take us where we got to go here
Lauren but you said we multiple times
do we need to pay this off and there is
no we unfortunately this is not okay so
not yet we're very close to like
engagement marriage very exciting okay
very exciting but until then nothing
until then this is his problem
yes and I hate it for him but I I agree
with Rachel
um I would be reaching out with with the
the olive fridge you know the metaphor
to say hey
so can I get my name off this can I
would you work with me on this
yeah you don't want to be with me yeah
I'm okay with that you know I would try
to negotiate that on good faith to say
hey
help me out do me a solid I tried to
help you out yeah that was not so smart
that's right
um but again it would take her
she's got to play ball she's and and and
if she doesn't it's like that's it I
mean but when we get this call with cars
houses you know this is a new trend by
the way I haven't asked you what you
think of this the new trend is and I'm
sure you know of this but a lot of
single people that may just be friends
they're not even romantically connected
well they're trying they're buying
houses together with both names trying
to get equity and all their own because
they can't afford to buy a house on
their own so they're going okay I'm
really good friends with my buddy Bob
yeah and so Bob and Larry are going to
buy a house together and it's like that
can't end well no but this is a thing
that's happening names on the deed and
the mortgage all of it yeah no they'll
do that I know because in the moment it
feels like a really Smart Financial
yeah what if a three or four go together
they all go well wait a second I can put
my down payment in you put yours in and
four of us become roommates one house
yep and then and not just roommates but
owning owners ownership you're right
within it but they think oh it's a smart
roommate playing we all get a little bit
of equity and it's gonna be and then and
then Bob goes off doing Bob's thing
why are all these people 80 years old I
think it's funnier because if I said
Eric it's not funny but if I say Bob
meets Luanne that's funny but if it's
Eric and Meredith it's not funny that's
why I go with the older names but there
really is something here don't do that
we're having fun with this but this gets
really contentious now what you can do
we've heard people do this is they go
and they buy
um you know a starter town home or condo
they get two roommates not on the
mortgage not ownership that's the point
they help pay the the mortgage and all
that you know that's sure that's a
that's a play too you're offering them a
discount with when it comes to ownership
yeah I mean any level of sharing until
unless you're married and there's a
legal binding
contract there uh other than that not
smart too not smart co-signed on put
your name on people's debt don't go in
together think you're gonna get a better
deal with equity in the house and all
that because Bob and Luanne man they are
Trump they're gonna go do their thing
and poor Larry loses his pal
and he may lose a lot of his money don't
do it Bob not worth it Larry
bee Pals you know play golf whatever it
is you do don't co-sign on a mortgage
and all that stuff it just never works
out there you go and Luanne is the bad
girl in all of it because she won Bob's
heart how did this all go so bad because
you didn't buy it the right way for
yourself